Olá hoje eu vou conversar com vocês
sobre a Glutamina que é um dos 20
aminoácidos que encontramos em alimentos
ricos em proteínas aqui o Dr Alan Dutra
médico h mais de 25 anos temos muitas
perguntas interessantes para esclarecer
sobre a Glutamina Quais são os seus
benefícios quem pode aproveitar ao
máximo o suplemento E quem deve passar
longe dele também como usar de forma
segura se ela deve ser tomada em jejum
ou com alimentos e é claro não poderia
deixar de falar sobre a polêmica que
envolve Glutamina e o câncer Então vamos
lá pessoal quando falamos na Glutamina
ela é mais do que um simples aminoácido
ela é o mais abundante dos aminoácidos
na nossa corrente sanguínea e é uma Peça
chave na construção de proteínas que são
os alices de todas as nossas células
quando falamos de aminoácidos estamos
falando da essência de nossa saúde do
combustível que mantém a máquina do
nosso corpo funcionando a pleno vapor
agora sem a Glutamina a nossa estrutura
essa fábrica incrível não poderia operar
de forma eficiente a Glutamina é super
utilizada pelas células do nosso corpo
olha o tamanho da importância da
glutamina pessoal bom as proteínas que
consumimos na nossa dieta são compostas
por longas cadeias de ácidos ligados por
ligações peptídicas durante a nossa
digestão enzimas específicas como as
proteases quebram essas ligações
peptídicas nas proteínas liberando
aminoácidos individuais ou pequenas
cadeiras de aminoácidos então esses
aminoácidos livres são absorvidos pelo
intestino delgado e transportados para
corrente sanguínea onde podem ser
utilizados pelas nossas células do corpo
para sintetizar novas proteínas que são
necessárias para várias funções como
reparo celular crescimento produção de
enzimas e hormônios entre outras funções
vitais então a Glutamina se destaca por
ser o aminoácido essencial essencial
mesmo no sentido de que sem ela certas
proteínas simplesmente não podem ser
formadas isso mostra o quão Vital ela é
para a nossa saúde e Nutrição
independentemente da fonte proteína que
você preferir como animal vegetal a
Glutamina é chave mas é importante saber
que as proteínas animais tendem a
fornecer aminoácidos mais digeríveis do
que as proteínas vegetais pessoal Aqui
vai um ponto Super Interessante em
momentos de estresse para o corpo seja
por catabolismo que é quando perdemos
tecidos ou quando temos infecções
inflamações ou até mesmo após uma
cirurgia uma queimadura a a demanda do
nosso corpo Glutamina vai lá para cima
isso só reforça o papel Vital que ela
desempenha não só na manutenção da nossa
saúde mas também na nossa recuperação
agora você pode se perguntar tá mas como
que eu posso me beneficiar de
suplementos de Glutamina e existem
momentos em que ela não é de fato
recomendada Então vamos desvendar essas
questões mas eu tenho que falar que
existe um debate acalorado sobre
Glutamina e uma condição específica o
câncer Esse é um ponto delicado
extremamente importante da nossa
conversa o uso da glutamina por
pacientes diagnosticados com câncer Eu
quero deixar uma coisa bem clara desde o
início até agora não existe evidência de
que o consumo de Glutamina cause câncer
mas quando falamos de pacientes que já
estão enfrentando essa doença a história
muda um pouco pessoal pacientes com
câncer muitas vezes enfrentam uma grande
perda de energia especialmente nas fases
mais avançadas da doença Lembra que eu
falei que a Glutamina é super utilizada
pelas células do corpo como importante
fonte de energia O problema é que ela
não só alimenta nossas células saudáveis
mas infelizmente também pode alimentar
as células cancerígenas Esse é um ponto
fundamental que precisamos entender a
Glutamina nutre todas as células do
corpo sem distinção se por um lado
Glutamina essencial pra saúde do nosso
intestino e pra nossa energia quando
falamos em câncer ela também pode acabar
alimentando as células malignas vamos
dar uma pausa aqui e falar sobre como o
câncer se alimenta todos nós já ouvimos
falar que o açúcar é digamos um prato
preferido do Câncer certo essa relação
foi até mesmo evidenciada por um
cientista alemão do início do século
passado que ganhou até o prêmio Nobel
professor descoberta sobre o metabolismo
do câncer e o açúcar pessoal a
voracidade do Câncer pelo açúcar é bem
documentada e um bom exemplo disso é o
exame de petscan esse exame é usado para
localizar o câncer do corpo funciona
através da detecção de células malignas
que consomem uma grande quantidade de
glicose marcada o que mostra pra gente o
apetite insaciável do Câncer pelo açúcar
então o açúcar indiscutivelmente a
primeira e maior fonte de alimento para
o câncer agora o segundo alimento
preferido pro câncer e aqui está a parte
que muitos podem não conhecer é a
Glutamina e é por isso que especialmente
em contexto de suplementação a Glutamina
pode ser
contraindicada para pacientes com câncer
estamos diante de um paradoxo enquanto a
Glutamina é vital paraa saúde e energia
do nosso corpo ela também pode alimentar
as vias metabólicas que sustentam o
crescimento do Câncer por isso alguns
médicos indicam também como parte do
tratamento em casos de câncer uma dieta
vegetariana reduzindo um pouco o consumo
das proteínas que são mais ricas em
Glutamina mas atenção para as pessoas
saudáveis sem diagnóstico de câncer a
Glutamina continua sendo uma aliada
poderosa paraa saúde Especialmente
quando falamos de nutrição
saúde intestinal recuperação muscular e
fortalecimento do sistema imunológico
agora vamos pro lado bom da coisa mas se
ficou alguma dúvida sobre a Glutamina
deixe sua pergunta nos comentários que é
assim que possível eu responderei Então
pessoal se você tem uma doença
inflamatória como por exemplo doença de
crom ou uma doença celíaca qualquer
patologia intestinal essas doenças podem
levar a uma condição conhecida como
intestino hiper permeável ou liqu Gut
onde o revestimento do intestino fica
danificado permitindo que partículas de
alimentos bactérias e outros elementos
entrem na corrente sanguínea isso pode
desencadear uma reação inflamatória em
alguns casos até levar ao
desenvolvimento de doenças autoimunes Eu
tenho um ponto interessante para contar
para vocês o Sir Hans adol CBS o
bioquímico que descobriu o ciclo de CBS
foi o primeiro a recomendar a iglut
Amina para tratar problemas intestinais
Krebs foi um ganhador do prêmio Nobel e
Ele identificou que a Glutamina ajuda a
melhorar a resposta imunológica no
intestino Fantástico isso né pessoal e
pesquisas seguintes confirmaram que a
leg Glutamina pode normalizar respostas
imunes e reduzir a inflamação intestinal
auxiliando também na recuperação de
sensibilidades alimentares porque quando
a gente está com o intestino hiper
permeável a gente começa a reagir a tudo
fica com sensibilidades alimentares
diversas e com isso descobrimos que a
Glutamina desempenha um papel Vital na
manutenção de uma microbiota intestinal
saudável e na imunidade geral reduzindo
a colonização por patógenos o que pode
diminuir o risco de problemas variados
um estudo de 2018 divulgado na revista
nutrients descobriu que a Glutamina é
muito importante pro nosso sistema de
defesa o sistema imune isso porque ela
vai ajudar as células de defesa do corpo
conhecida como
linfócitos se multiplicarem e a
produzirem substâncias que combatem
infecções Além disso ela auxilia outras
células imunológicas os macrófagos a
literalmente engolir e destruir
micróbios nocivos e ainda vai ajudar na
eliminação de bactérias por um tipo de
célula chamada neutrófilos por isso a
Glutamina é recomendada na dieta de
pessoas com o sistema imunológico
enfraquecido agora falando melhor de
doenças intestinais existem milhões de
pessoas enfrentando a tal da síndrome do
intestino hiper permeável é importante
entender que essa condição é
frequentemente a raiz o gatilho das
doenças
autoimunes damina sendo a principal
fonte de combustível paraas células do
nosso intestino delgado ela tem se
mostrado eficaz na promoção da Saúde
intestinal ajudando a reparar a parede
danificada E tratando esse intestino
danificado e com Buraquinhos outras
pesquisas incluindo um estudo da lanet
mostrou que a suplementação com
Glutamina L Glutamina pode diminuir essa
hiperpermeabilidade
intestinal e também sugeriu benefícios
para condições como com lítio cativa e
doença inflamatória intestinal além de
ser promissora no tratamento de úlceras
estomacais oferecendo uma alternativa
natural aos antibióticos além da
imunidade saúde intestinal a Glutamina é
uma verdadeira aliada para quem busca
melhorar o desempenho Atlético acelerar
a recuperação muscular e aumentar o
metabolismo sabia que durante um treino
pesado o seu corpo vai precisar de mais
glutamina do que você consome na sua
dieta e após um exercício intenso os
níveis dessa substância podem cair
bastante o que pode levar o corpo a
buscar energia nos músculos ao invés de
usar os carboidratos Isso não é legal
porque você pode prejudicar quem está
tentando ganhar músculos certo a
Glutamina pode ajudar a prevenir a perda
muscular apoiando seus músculos a se
recuperarem isso porque ela ajuda a
aumentar a força e a reparar os tecidos
muscular mais rapidamente reduzindo o
tempo de
recuperação isso vale também para outras
situações como feridas ou queimaduras ou
qualquer recuperação de tecidos a
Glutamina pode ser uma grande aliada
para sua saúde metabólica e cardíaca
isso porque estudos apontam que a sua
suplementação pode aumentar bastante os
níveis do hormônio do crescimento humano
o que acelera o metabolismo e pode
ajudar na queima de gordura
e na construção de músculos magros ou a
massa magra isso é especialmente
interessante para quem busca perder peso
ou melhorar a composição corporal em
diabéticos tipo 2 A suplementação
Glutamina mostrou melhorias na saúde
cardiovascular e na composição corporal
beneficiando não apenas Quem tem
diabetes mas também Quem está lutando
contra a vontade constante de consumir
açúcar e carboidratos pessoal e a
Glutamina desempenha um papel
interessante também na saúde do cérebro
como precursora do
neurotransmissor glutamato ela é
fundamental para manter esse equilíbrio
no cérebro e pode ajudar a prevenir e
tratar uma série de condições
neurológicas incluindo ansiedade
depressão epilepsia transtorno bipolar
esquizofrenia e até mesmo a dependência
de álcool estudos mostram que a
Glutamina pode ajudar a proteger o
cérebro de danos e retardar o
envelhecimento cerebral certo pessoal
são muitos benefícios importantes mas eu
falei especialmente dos principais
aqueles que têm mais estudos realizados
Mas então qual seria a dose ideal
normalmente recomendo 5 g de Glutamina
de uma a três vezes ao dia isso vai
depender de cada caso por isso é
importante fazer uso Com acompanhamento
de um médico nutricionista mas uma dose
5 G ao a dia é bastante segura Bom se
você está passando por um período onde o
sono é escasso o trabalho é excessivo ou
qualquer situação está exigindo demais
de você saiba que esse estresse contínuo
pode afetar negativamente a sua saúde
geral nesses momentos a Glutamina emerge
Como suporte importante ela atua
melhorando nossa capacidade de
antioxidante e contribui
significativamente pra saúde intestinal
minimizando risco de infecções ou perda
excessiva de massa muscular Então esse é
um momento interessante para considerar
usar a Glutamina quando mais podemos
usá-la como ela é uma aliada na proteção
do intestino você pode incluir a
Glutamina especialmente durante o uso de
antibióticos você pode tomar a Glutamina
cerca de 10 minutos antes de um
antibiótico Porque isso pode ajudar a
proteger o seu intestino dos efeitos
adversos dos medicamentos reduzindo a
permeabilidade aumentada que aquela
medicação vai causar é uma prática que
eu recomendo durante todo o ciclo do
antibiótico para preservar a integridade
intestinal como ela já se mostrou
bastante eficaz Especialmente porque o
intestino Aproveita bem a Glutamina
paraa própria saúde é preferível que
você tome em jejum para que o intestino
possa absorver e utilizar o aminoácido
de uma maneira mais eficiente assim você
pode consumir a contamina a acordar em
jejum ou antes de dormir também em jejum
para garantir que o intestino seja o
principal beneficiado por outro lado se
você tem sensibilidade estomacal ou a
saúde intestinal está muito
bagunçada consumir Glutamina com
alimentos pode ser mais apropriado no
seu caso promovendo uma absorção mais
suave diminuindo possíveis desconfortos
gastrointestinais para uma absorção
ótima É aconselhável tomar glutamina com
estômago vazio especialmente se seu
objetivo é maximizar os seus benefícios
sistêmicos como melhoria da performance
esportiva ou recuperação muscular isso
evita competição com outros aminoácidos
doos alimentos facilitando uma absorção
direta Além disso para quem busca elevar
os níveis de hormônio do crescimento A
Glutamina pode ser uma excelente escolha
Você pode tomar a Glutamina antes de
dormir para potencializar a produção
desse hormônio durante o sono ou
consumi-la antes de exercícios em jejum
mas esteja ciente de que para alguns a
Glutamina antes de dormir pode levar a
insônia Se esse for o caso ajustar o
horário da ingestão será necessário
espero que essa conversa tenha
esclarecido algumas dúvidas e quem sabe
te inspirado a cuidar mais da sua saúde
muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande braço um beijo no seu coração
você é
feira